Oh
don't get weird I know it's weird right
now but I'm not dead I'm here
I'm telling the story all right you can
unclick your bot holes this isn't this
isn't ghost comedy how you doing ladies
can I interest you in this is not
happening
I'm your host Roy Wood jr. Roy I did it
again
hello Roy
how's the water on does it feel
I live in New York City I've been there
for ten years originally I'm from Denver
Colorado
I grew up in Aurora yeah people stopped
cheering after you say that but for five
years I lived in Tucson Arizona which
it's reasoner's won applause that that's
a real nice group there are good people
in Tucson but I found most of them to be
angry son Bert white people just walking
around like all these Mexicans do it
thank you but they're supposed to be
here you're not that's why you're burnt
all the time go back to the Great Lakes
and eat curdled cheese's it's what us
paints do best when I lived in Tucson I
went to school there but I also lived
with a drug dealer which I can't
recommend enough if you do drugs
if you do drugs live with a drug dealer
it's like living at Costco it's just
free samples every day and then Costco
gets robbed then you're like you know I
don't think I should have a Costco is a
bad idea I really got my life together
at this point but when I moved to Tucson
my first and best friend that I made
there was a guy named Amir who was an
Israeli kid from Long Island and yeah I
don't know if that's true Israeli or
Long Island but keep it moving forward
those are two you know but Amir was the
first real person I met from Long Island
and he was very Long Island
he was very like a brawl like everything
that just existed as a sentence filler
like yam brawl he would do these things
that certain people in Long Island do
that there are questioned statements so
he says his statement but it's framed
like a question so he'd come in the
living room and be like yo these Nikes
al right yes I don't know if that's the
desired response Aamir was very good at
selling weed he was very good at it it
was a natural habit that he just picked
up and ran with freshman year it started
it you know 20 bags and then eights and
then sophomore year it was like quarters
and half ounces then I moved in with him
and it went to like ounces two quarter
pounds you know that our lease ran up
but the furniture was getting good so I
you know released I was like yeah let's
keep going with this
he started getting to like pounds and
then you know he got a fish tank
hey drug dealers
stop with the fish tanks it's happy now
it's also stupid you're gonna have a
flood care about your other possessions
please I'm sorry I'm really hyped up
about this as you could tell but I
didn't have to sell drugs I just I just
smoked his weed and looked at his fish
tank so it was a pretty good deal
one day I'm going to do laundry I'm a
broke college student I have six loads
of laundry in six plastic bags like I'm
moving out of a girlfriend's
house who has a drug problem it's like
I'm serious Donna I am gone now but I
fill up my car go I go to the bank and I
turned ten dollars into ten dollars and
quarters at the time I'm wearing cargo
shorts a liquor t-shirt and a swimsuit
is underwear because it was laundry day
I'm not I'm not that giant of a piece of
her I'm just like Rock take shower
with it on it washes it it's pretty much
yeah takes care of itself so I go and I
change 10 dollars into five dollars and
quarters which I put on my right leg and
five dollars in quarters that I put on
my left leg so when I walk around it
makes a noise like I sound like the
shittiest sheriff in the West it's like
pearl blitz is awful
it was awful so I have my pocket to
change I get to my car and a mirror
calls me and he's like yeah we're
getting robbed and like I don't is that
a question or a statement you got to
tell me right now cuz this is very
dangerous
he's like y'all's gonna do a deal and
these guys came by and you know I think
they're trying to rob me so you know I
called off the deal
all right he's like well you drive
around the neighborhood and see if
they're there or not
sure whatever I'm driving a 1996 Dodge
Stratus it's a real hunk of so I
probably just look like feds to them but
I I do a lap I don't see anybody so I
pull into our carport that's under our
apartment and standing there when I get
out of the car the first guys
this six foot four piece of white trash
like you gotta understand something me
when I was a little kid my dad moved to
this town in Northern California that
grows like the biggest pieces of white
trash
[Music]
so at 33 I like to fancy myself a little
bit of a white trash sommelier and this
guy was a top-shelf piece of yeah
he was covered in tattoos that I can
only describe as Mountain Dew tattoos
the same way an adult would like drink a
whole can of Mountain Dew would be like
what fire balls on my elbows that
doesn't sound right but sure and
standing with them is this five foot
four Southside Tucson cholo blood in
blood out like what's the white boy like
that like oh hi they're standing there
and I get out and the little cholos like
ain't my tommy green live here I'm like
that's a terrible thing and now I rob a
drug dealer change up the even if
there's ramen a coke dealer he's like a
mark below here clearly a synonym for
what you're trying to get from but I'm
like no no it's here so he they leave
they both of them walk off I go upstairs
and the mirrors there and he's like
y'all did you see anybody I told him
like yeah it's big piece of white trash
little blood and blood out and
he's like yeah he's like yeah y'all
those are the guys and I'm like oh
well they're gone they left we look out
we don't see them so you know we do it
drug dealers and their roommates do and
we smoke weed and play play safe I'm
about to smoke a cigarette and I grabbed
the barbecue lighter that I used to
smoke cigarettes
because I'm a little bit of garbage
myself Amir Amir gets a call and he's
like y'all the deals back on they want
to do the deal for five pounds but
they're gonna do it what I'm gonna do is
I'm a walk to the street and then get in
a car and I'm like okay he's like yo
will you walk near the car and I'm I'm
very high and on weed and victories of
Madden if a mirror watches this you
knows I'm telling the truth
I ran that but he's like yeah will
you walk me to the car you're gonna
smoke a cigarette and I'm like all right
and then as I go to the door he goes
y'all get the gun now
if you've lived in Arizona you know how
insanely easy it is to get a handgun
it's like buying socks you just walk in
a gun and they're like here's your dog
look it's pretty dangerous but I was
with a mirror and we went to a gun show
and I'm not joking the first thing he
said to the first gun dealer he met was
yeah what she cheap his gun like that's
not what I want to hear as the person
that lives next to you and knows you're
buying this for self-defense what he did
is he did buy the cheapest gun possible
it had a metal slide but a plastic
handle he bought a plastic gun by the
way we took it to the range it never
shot straight the bullet always bent
like some trick shot in an action movie
right
so mirrors like y'all get the gun and I
tell him I'm like I'm not using
that thing and he goes and then with
this like aggressive Long Island energy
he's like y'all you pick like like he
was mad at me he's mad at me for
questioning why I want to bring a gun
through a drug deal and he's like y'all
you dumbass what'll happen is if they
got a knife and you show them the gun
then they're not gonna be scared they're
gonna leave and for some reason I
believe that rock-paper-scissors correct
so I put the gun in my cargo shorts I
grabbed the camera light in the barbecue
lighter my mirror has an athletic bag
full of five pounds he walks out in
front of me now I have $10 and quarters
on me you can hear me coming from a mile
when I walk I sound like a knight and
shitty chainmail so we start walking
down the stairs right we'll get to the
bottom of the stairs mountain
dew tattoos comes around gun drawn gets
to a mirror the tiny vato comes
right up the stairs dawn on my chest
like perfectly right on my chest don't
get weird I know it's weird right now
but I'm not dead I'm here I'm
telling the story all right you can
unclench your buttholes this isn't this
isn't ghost comedy
Roy Roy didn't come up here in that
loud-ass jacket like the other side so I
got a 45 right pointing right in the
middle of my chest and I'm a child of
the 80s I grew up with Schwarzenegger
movies in Stallone movies and always in
those action movies when a bad guy pulls
out a gun on the hero they always say
some cool like you better use that
turns out I don't I get very polite if
you put a gun on my customer service
voice would you mind filling out a brief
survey and as I do that I lift my hands
up I've already blown the rules
apparently of a robbery because this
guy's furious that my hands are up he's
like put your hands up what you
I'm like all right and he
grabs that he when I did that I lifted
my shirt high enough that he saw the
handle of the gun so he takes the gun
off of my waistband and he's like go
back inside yeah
[Applause]
and I'm standing on this second floor of
this apartment looking out over my
stairwell like I didn't really know my
dad that well he could be part flying
squirrel
nothing great if I took off and just
drifted away he's like the white
boys are flying now but it's like turn
around go back inside of my all
right and I turn around and as I do he
takes my gun the gun that he took off me
and hits me in the back of the
head now I'm very lucky to have a minor
role on the Showtime show billions but
the best piece of acting I've ever done
in my life is getting hit in the head by
a 5 foot 3 dude holding a plastic gun
Oh
[Applause]
swing it like a Norwegian God swings a
hammer so I go to the ground and
immediately right when I go to the
ground you know he puts me he's zip ties
pulls out zip ties he zip ties my arms
behind my back
he duct-taped my legs together and then
he pulls out an army duffel bag and just
starts ransacking our apartment if I
could Yelp a robbery five stars type
rata sum material he was prompt he was
direct he had clearly done this before
mr. mark of a true professional
he starts robbing he goes around our
house he grabs everything is then he
starts taking his 45 and coming over to
my head and he starts going where's the
money white boy the creepiest laugh at
that point that sinister ass laugh from
behind me
first off from telling the story you
know I don't trust anyone behind me like
that
like an old mafia boss I don't like
anyone sitting behind me been here boy
hahahaha of course you were scared you
felt your life leaning from you he takes
the 45 and he keeps going up to me and
he keeps like pushing it on my temple
goal was the money white boy was the
money white but now I'm fine being
called white boy I've been called white
boy my whole life the only time it's
things is when I know for a fact I'm a
foot taller than you he's like where's
the money white boy my package so dunk
on you
[Laughter]
so I keeps going where's the money when
I go I don't know I don't know and I
noticed I start getting this like my
tone goes from scared like bitchy with
the morning with I don't know I don't
and real ad at a restaurant like I
ordered that diet coke ten minutes ago I
think that's my one critique of black
comedians who do impressions of white
people is they always make us so corny
and over enunciate they really miss the
in us in our voice when we feel
like we've been over here man I
need to speak to someone that's like
whoo that is angry pink right there I'm
yelling at this guy like we've been
dating for 15 years he's like where's
the money why point like I don't know
but we're supposed to be at my sister's
in a half-hour so he takes my keys and
he takes my wallet and the wallet that I
had at that time a girlfriend had bought
me pulp fiction's one of my favorite
movies of all time
and yeah my girlfriend bought me the bad
wallet and then I ran into
a bad and that is how you
define irony is when someone takes a
joke wallet off you that's supposed to
be interpreted as badass this guy was
like oh this guy's sucks to be in a band
he takes my keys he said don't
move and he goes downstairs and I hear
him start my car and if you drive a
piece of you always kind of wanted
to get taken like he I heard him start
that car and I was like yeah
Toyota Tacoma or two-seater I'm already
thinking about the truck I'm gonna buy
it's perfect for the desert it's
affordable and I looked at the Kelly
Blue Book right in my range
it comes back upstairs it goes you
move again white boy imma
kill you I'm like alright I'm
sitting here he goes downstairs
I hear them turning the car into reverse
and I hear him pull away and immediately
think did you rob me or did I rob you
and then I realize I'm wearing swimsuit
his underpants and he just took all my
laundry and I was like I think you just
robbed me I'm gonna have to wear these
for the foreseeable future I count to
about 3035 and then I just pure
adrenaline break the plastic restraints
hop over to the door lock it and light
up that camel light cuz there's not a
better cigarette than after you've had a
gun pointed at you
oh that's flavor country as I light up
that cigarette I see my cell phone it's
a flip phone cuz it's 2004 it's dancing
its dancing sick pant pant pant yeah
yeah and I don't know the number and I
pick up and all I hear is y'all are you
dead yeah mirror there's good cell phone
reception in heaven he's like yeah that
guy came around the corner I just got
rid of the bag and I jumped and ran
around the corner where are you I'm like
on our apartment I explained like the
guy took our car we have to call the
cops because he's got my car and I got
to report this car stolen if I'm gonna
get that two-seater
we come back we cleared the drugs out of
the apartment I call the cops they take
down a report all this two weeks
later I'm at a bar in Tucson Arizona and
I get a call on my cell phone
like mr. soda it's the Tucson Police
Department we have found your 1996 Dodge
Stratus I don't think my response was
supposed to be
eight he waits a second he goes mr.
Russell you're in the police port says
your uh sister wallet was stolen can you
describe it for me
yeah it's the ones this bad
on it and the caponata means to beat
this goes well clearly you've met a
pattern
[Music]
hopper an open-mic her help makes that
kind of an inappropriate joke to a
robbery victim but alright I think
that's the thing man like you know I've
told the story several times my friends
and there's always this part where I
have to explain that comedians we use
our sense of humor is like a self
defense mechanism which up
happens to us we try to make ourselves
laugh and that just kind of makes it
better
I've made myself laugh during the
robbery and all my friends were like
yeah you should get checked that's
up but what happened was during
the robbery when he had the 45 on my
head and he kept going where's the money
white boy where's the money white boy I
was like I don't know and
finally goes where's your money white
boy I don't have any I'm broke his
cuz I was he hears that he goes I find
more than a dollar on you I'm gonna
kill you to which my response
was dis change count you might never
seen an angry or criminal then someone
waiting around pockets full of change
searching for a lost dollar the anger on
his face like I was just some
disappointing white pinata look like
this guy sucks
alright you guys a lot of fun